so your woman in tech I am so you're
definitely oppressed as we know since
the oppressed
I'm women in tech and I'm a female
entrepreneur so I am at I am double
intersectionally hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster
I'm constant in kitchen and this is a
show for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about and trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
serial entrepreneur and the co-founder
of tick just put your welcome to
trigonometry thank you for having me
[Music]
before we get into the interview I just
not as Francis as replace the word off
with the word with which you've been
getting a lot of [ __ ] no I have and
social peer pressure's is finally you've
crumbled me yeah I know I know he's no
karateka correct but it's a
colloquialism of where I come from but
you two you vicious bullying bastards
you have you've impinged on me and it's
made me sad anyway you've made him
improve his grandma sorry Jess that was
just totally random yeah very warm
welcome to trigonometry we obviously
know exactly who you are but tell us a
little bit about for our viewers what's
your journey through life how are you
where you are
how have you ended up sitting in the
chair would you currently sir oh the
short version I'll give you the short
version
I'm from the Midlands I've worked very
hard at losing the accent I am the
product of a very very happy sort of
middle-class upbringing two siblings
very supportive parents and and I've
been in London since graduation I had
this crappiest messiest CV or ever where
I kind of jumped jobs every two years
because I'd get bored or it couldn't be
managed all of it which was one of just
really enjoying working on the front end
I was in the sales and the marketing of
disruptive
businesses that we're trying to change
behaviors and I guess what I always was
on which I now AM cut to the end of the
story is I always wanted to be an
entrepreneur I always wanted to build
businesses I always wanted to be my own
boss I guess but I it took me a long
time I guess to get the confidence and
cause the golden bullet of an idea to do
that as I kept riding the coattails of
all these other entrepreneurs in my
twenties in a very scrappy way and
learning from some of the best and also
some of the worst about you know how to
build businesses and then I met my
business partners at my my first company
which was Blippar which I started in
2011 and that was for for some years one
of the big tech success stories that
came out of the UK were the global
pioneer in the augmented reality space
my job again sales marketing
communications building brands and media
interest helping with investment and it
was a thrilling ride you know we went
global we were talking on stages all
over the world and and really you know
disrupting something and I loved the
story of that and it was certainly the
most on and alive I've ever felt in my
life
building that business and that's just
given me the hook and I'm now and now I
was for a couple of years I moved into a
sort of advisory consulting role whereas
working with a lot of other startups
helping to scale them give them advice
did some investing consultancy and then
a year ago I got my head turned and now
I am back at the bottom of the pile
building another tech business for my
sins a really really exciting very very
ambitious micro video platform business
for user-generated how-to content and
yeah I'm back at there on the roller
coaster again it's very exciting so your
woman in tech I am so you're definitely
oppressed as we know since the oppressed
and women in tech and I'm a female
entrepreneur so I am at it I am I'm
double intersectionally there's two
labels and and yeah and I guess because
I the the journey between blippo and
tech involved a couple of years
town to the front seats of that business
because I had three children in four
years Wow
yeah bit foolish with hindsight
obviously hugely rewarding but it just
meant that I was kind of less inclined
to do the hundred hour work weeks of my
life on a plane and I needed to reclaim
some balance and frankly sanity to my
day-to-day so I have sort of a year and
a half two years at home and it was
during that time that I really started
to think about in more depth and explore
this apparent depression or not
oppression this sort of discrimination
within these two fields that I was so
closely connected with in which I was
being invited to talk about on platforms
all the time and there are a number of
sort of catalysts to my thinking at that
time and the first was my mother
actually I took her to a speaking event
that I was at whereas being interviewed
about how hard it was to be a woman in
tech and I was very good at this line I
you know I had all the stories and it
was only afterwards that she sat me down
over a glass of wine she said tell me
has it been hard how was it being hard I
wouldn't you know I really genuinely
just want to understand how how it's
been hard for you and I kept telling
these stories and she doesn't your story
that someone else's story that's not
your story someone else's story have you
found it hot because what I've seen is
that you're getting more opportunities
to speak on platforms and then of your
male business partners you keep getting
these award nominations certain only a
black male business partner you get a
lot of PR and column inches and have you
found it hard and the way she grilled me
on this I kind of thought mmm I am using
other people's stories and I am I saying
this sort of stock line on an actual
fact it has it hasn't been hard
I've actually loved being a minority
within my two spheres because it does
enable me to stand out it enables me to
get recognition and then I also started
to think about how I got all those
opportunities and I realized that so
much of it had come from the love and
support of the men in my life you know
that those men who really believed in me
which started with my incredible father
who choose
brought me up thinking I could be and do
anything the boys could be there was no
concept of you're gonna find it harder
than your brother none of that you know
whatever you want to be you can be you
know how can I help you
you know what what should we talk about
today what's interesting you at the
moment and then business bosses but I
had mentors that I had people that I
looked up to they always supported me
and pushed me forward and gave me
opportunities and I'm now fortunate
enough to be married to a wonderful man
who does that he really enjoys my
success is a bore at dinner parties and
always wants to tell people what I've
been doing no you know my wife's got an
MBA and and then I started to think well
actually some of the people that I've
had the biggest challenges in my
professional life have been women I'm
not allowed to say that you know that is
but ultimately I don't subscribe to this
this identity box definitely said I'm
not a female entrepreneur and I started
to resent that you know I'm just an
entrepreneur and I want recognition for
building great businesses I don't want
people to buy my product because I'm a
woman I don't want any special favors
because I'm a woman but I always felt
this slight sense of conflict because
obviously I do have a product to sell so
if there's positive discrimination to be
taken advantage of then absolutely I
will do it back and I also fear the
conflict because it's not like I'm
saying the whole narrative is is wrong I
do believe that women respond very well
to role models and I understand a lot of
the initiatives behind these awards and
the publicity and the the media
narrative around getting more women into
the public eye and getting them to share
their story because younger women
including myself when I was younger are
hugely affected by seeing people like
them succeeding and that is very
empowering as far as being able to
identify with that and and see yourself
in that position and of course we come
in all different shapes and sizes it's
not the so Deborah media Ness dragon in
business it's you know sort of scrappy
skateboarding girls and pink haired
girls and
every color every every age introverts
extroverts you know it's really
important I think women do get
influenced by that so a lot of what's
happening within I guess the diversity
industry and my two fields I support and
I'm actively involved in but I stopped
will draw the line when it comes to the
over emphasis around discrimination and
disadvantage because I think when you
start tipping into negativity and
definition of ourselves around our
gender I I have less time for that
because I ultimately I think it does
girls and women any favors and you think
there's a problem with the tech industry
and women in particular and attracting
women do you think it's it's
male-dominated and you know and
therefore it's harder for a woman to
make her way I know you've got your
story but somebody else's story could be
different yeah and there's no question
it's male-dominated there's no question
about that so the second part is it
harder for them to make their way no I
don't believe it is I mean if they if
they're going to feel uncomfortable in a
majority male environment then they
might feel less inclined to it
but I don't believe it's harder I think
that there's been an overcorrection
there and there's a lot of positive
discrimination for women coming into the
technology space which I don't agree
with either because I perhaps naively a
meritocratic I believe it should always
be best person for the job but it's a
vibrant buzzy exciting sector and very
few women that I know that come into it
you know have day-to-day anxiety within
that sector and also tech isn't really
an industry I also get a bit cross with
that as a definition
everything's tech there's no business in
the world right now that isn't tech in
some in some way and there's so many
creative media communications product
opportunities that aren't pure coding
but we seem to obsess on that
under-representation within the
technology job specifically and the fact
that that's apparently having an impact
on how products are designed and they
don't have way
mind and that certainly has been
occasioned them some high-profile
examples of that so I'm glad to see some
of that being corrected but I doubt fair
I think I fan tastic industry for women
and mostly women all the women I say are
doing tremendously well within it and I
would love to see more women in it but
I'm afraid I believe in the difference
is the average differences between the
predilection of men and women and it's
borne out time and time again in the
data as far as their aptitudes and
interests in certain types of fields of
science for example and more people
softer social interests than things you
know there is evidence for that and I
find it compelling before we get into
that I just wanted to go back for a mom
can I just stop I just want to make it
well I was attracted to Aurora okay well
there you are I was gonna ask you if we
go back a little bit before we get into
the details of the kind of men and women
all the rest of it I was interested that
you've had a journey of kind of almost a
transition from a particular way of
talking about this issue to a totally
different one
what do you think it was the made you
talk about you know discrimination and
all that stuff from that perspective in
the first place that is really it was a
journey and it was actually quite
accidental it was something I was
feeling and sort of disillusioned with
for a long time but also very very
nervous about putting my head above the
parapet on so I was conscious that I'd
be swimming against the stream that
frankly I work within you know all these
people great friends of mine and I
actually meant when you were talking
about how there is discrimination hmm
what was it that pushed you to do that
in the first place before you ah because
that was what everyone was saying it's
really hard to be within these sectors I
mean that's what the
that that would almost be the title of
the session that I'd be in so it was
inviting us to all relay those moments
when we've been the only woman in a room
and you know the client has been talking
that we've been talked over or you know
someone who directed comments to junior
male colleagues here next to us so I
guess I was yeah I guess I heard so many
of those stories that I am I felt well I
must have some to contribute and you
know and that there is a problem here
and there has been a problem there I
should say you know I don't believe that
that problem totally no longer exists so
I'm very far from that and you know I
think it's important that they're aired
but it's when we get to a stage that now
we're looking for everywhere and that's
kind of where we are now and that
troubles me I'll give a really cool
example actually because this week I on
Twitter I saw about 12 of my friends
reesh airing this tweet where a woman
had applied for a credit card and she
put her title as doctor and it's and
then her gender is female and this alert
had come up to say you know we don't
recognize that title all that gender and
of course she was horrified and she she
and within 24 hours fourteen point five
thousand likes and shares and and I just
thought seriously I work in tech I know
that those two fields are not in any way
connected on the back end and that no
computer is going to see those and sure
enough you know I followed this thread
down and some guy had replicated exactly
the same user experience bug that had
happened on the tech platform and and
yet the HuffPo would picked it up they
all wanted to talk about this sort of
misogyny in
in this product and this credit card
company is basically getting demonized
for what is a stupid UX technical bug
but it was the mob mentality there was
always this glee that oh look we found
another example of it and I kind of just
thought how is this doing women any
favors it's you know and it's not fair
to the company I feel sorry for the
women to fire a UX guy or or a look into
the back end a bit but that's not what
this was it had nothing to do with that
and that to me is so symptomatic of
where we've got to with the narrative
that looks for it everywhere you know
peppa pig's dad fixes the computer and
not the mum this is a gender stereotype
take aside the fact that peppa pig's
dad's a [ __ ] idiot
and then the men's rights hates Peppa
Pig because oh yeah because they think
that he's them he's you know he's just
portrayed as such a fool in everything
that he does which is my husband hates
it like this is what our children a
growing up see but the fact that he
fixed the computer and his wife didn't
is evidence of this sort of subconscious
indoctrination that we're doing of
children about gender roles I say I said
be a mom of three children and a five
and watching enough Peppa Pig and you'll
know that you've actually got that
entirely the wrong way around
I would never predict it that we would
have gone to Peppa Pig there's some kind
of children's book that talked about
fire men as opposed to fire I'm in Sam
it's the other big cause Dijon on the
how where indoctrinating children no
night seriously give chosen some credit
you know it's they just don't believe
they see it it's insidious and its
waiver that I don't think it is any more
I'm glad there's somebody at once
they've said actually you know there's a
little too much of this going on but I
don't find girl-power a particularly
compelling message from my daughter
either
I you know I find that all a bit I went
into Paper Chase and there's this whole
row for the glittery sparkly girl power
you know we can do it I fear the
patriarchy yeah
work with them you're not a girl first
you-you-you can see you know that you're
your own unique individual and you have
more in common with people that share
your values your outlook your upbringing
arguably you know then you do with
anyone because I happen to share your
the number of chromosomes and that to me
is what's worrying we do still people
down and then we exacerbate the
difference and that's like was all
identity politics not just the gender
debate do you think it's a problem as
well with these types of messages where
somebody would go oh I'm not going to go
into tech because somebody like me isn't
welcome or there is a problem with it
that's where my angle is entirely so I
did a TEDx on this and this is what I
was alluding to earlier the the fear I
felt for putting myself out there on
this line my my argument is that firstly
I'm an optimist I do believe that women
have many many more opportunities and
the narrative would have you believe and
secondly I fail at this victimhood
narrative is really damaging for how
women perceive themselves so I think
it's only going to exacerbate the
confidence gap that is already existent
in more women than men as a trait you
know as an average trait women are much
more subject to imposter syndrome the
confidence gap the men are and I was a
woman with all the opportunities in the
world a fantastic education a great
upbringing you know I I still had that
imposter syndrome I shouldn't have had
that so far I'm having it and I see it
among so many of the women that I mentor
that I work with you know there is this
sort of we say what we're good at we
don't oversell ourselves you know we ask
for what we want we don't ask for more
than that you know we said we apply for
jobs where we can do 80% of the job spec
where as a guide more like you do it 30
40 % there is this just sort of more
innate risk aversion in women and I feel
that the narrative encourages that
further it does two things one it will
make them more anxious about certain
fields where they're told they're going
to be discriminated against you know
they're not going to be walking into
those quite as bullish and as
confidently as I think they would
otherwise
and what was the second thing second
thing oh the second thing is that this
narrative lets them off the hook and
that's not good for them you know in my
fields when I meet with young female
entrepreneurs the number of times I've
heard people say I didn't get that
funding because you know they don't
invest in women or they're not you know
that it was a gender reason why I wasn't
taking her seriously in that scenario I
I've now got I guess the experience the
age of gravitas so I'm mentoring them to
actually say to them no actually I was
any pitch it wasn't good you know don't
let yourself off the hook you know you
need to take feedback and as an
individual and you need to constantly
south improve and look at what you can
do and even arguably even if it was due
to discrimination the most productive
reaction to that is not wounded
insecurity you know go quite someone
about how you might have been you know
gender discriminated against but it's to
actually go we'll come on then I'll show
you and take the onus to circumvent the
situation in some way you know
resilience it's it should be about
resilience and I feel that the narrative
of discrimination and victimhood
undermines both that confidence and also
that resilience and also the individual
onus to take ownership of you know how
you put yourself forward and to mold
yourself change yourself to the
circumstances as required which
everybody needs to as an individual man
or woman it's not that's not gendered
the point you make is it's really
important I feel because a lot of the
time you know we there seems to be this
narrative that women are more impressed
than ever but I used to be a teacher I
was a teacher for ten years
girls are outperforming boys on every
level in academia and they every level
and they're gonna go to university
they're outstripping boys I mean boys
seem to be the ones struggling
especially when it comes to the school
level yeah and that's another area of
the debate that's incredibly fraught
with nastiness and unpleasantness
because obviously in reaction to a lot
of the
feminist line you've now got men's
rights trying to excuse me draw
attention to you know where those
disparities exist and the date that the
data does speak for itself and I find it
pretty compelling you know whether it's
at performance at university whether
it's the fact that women in their 20s
and 30s are learning just as much
sometimes more than men and it's really
striking when in my field again when you
look at stem data and you know the the
ratios they're apparently being so off
what they are off whack if you only take
a very narrow definition of stem which
is engineering and computer science and
you know that that type of science if
you take in social science behavioral
science medical science you know
anything of a biological nature women
are 75% within those fields of science
and yet nobody's saying we need to level
up both sides you know we're only saying
there aren't enough women in computer
science a more women in in computing and
engineering I think they have so much to
contribute and and different balance of
the types of products that we're that
we're building but in order to achieve
that we need to talk them out over look
they were not going to just create these
women you know out of nowhere we need to
talk them out of the other choices that
they're making and and you know I would
certainly personally err on the side of
choice you know I don't believe women
should be talked out of things that they
want to go into and there's certainly
the sort of women that are picking those
behavioral or biological sciences as
opposed to the technical hard sciences
pretty bright women you know they're
picking those sciences so I trust them
to make those judgments and I don't
either want to be talking women out of
careers in arts and no social work in
media and you know the ratio fails an
edge he'll known are not out of
education but nobody's saying less women
in teaching please let's have more men
in teaching so it's all the
conversations being had in silos in the
underrepresented fields you know whether
that's for finance or it's in tech
and that's that to me is you can't have
them in isolation and the boys arguments
and the mend under-representation is is
never discussed and indeed you need a
different lifestyle disadvantages that
men as a group experience you can't even
bring up like what there's so many
there's so many and you know there's
there's suicide rates
there's homelessness rates rates of
depression rates of school dropouts
workplace deaths deaths in service of
course on frontline you've got
sentencing court disparity men receiving
you know sixty percent longer sentences
for the same crimes as women child
custody paternity cases domestic abuse
which actually you know a heavy
percentage of men you know suffer from
that and we never hear about that but
it's I don't know that it's helpful to
fight fire with fire yeah I think
sometimes the context is required to
help broaden and open up the Overton
Window a little bit and I think that's
where some of the more moderate voices
like myself are trying to just say well
hang on let's look at the full picture
before we dive deep into one particular
area but then you get into a stage where
there's this sort of competitive
victimhood which i think is where the
men's rights movement falls down there's
a lot of very smart people trying to
make these arguments and I guess just as
the feminists or the progressive
feminists would say we've got to
overcorrect in order to get back to
normal I suppose of men's rights feel
likewise and it overcorrect and
overstressed these things in order to at
least get some awareness for them
particularly in this sort of clickbait
you know headline-grabbing media world
and online world that we now live in
that it's it's just it's victimhood by
another name that's my biggest war hours
that's my concern
that's my biggest worry with it because
it encourages people to go to the other
extreme as well and for men men's rights
movement is never going to be
particularly success because people
don't tend to feel sorry for men in the
same way that they feel sorry for women
it just is just a fact of life you know
I feel sorry that we don't feel sorry I
feel sorry for men that we don't feel
sorry but but that's again you talk
about realities there's the biological
reality in my opinion because you look
at you talk about male deaths or the
workplace and all the rest of it men
evolved we evolved to be disposable in a
way that women are not if you think
about two tribes of ten people each
right yeah five men five women in each
tribe the tribe that sent its men off to
war only one man comes back you can
replenish your tribe at the same rate if
you send your women off to war it's not
the same so men are disposable
biologically in a way that women are not
and I think that until you know until we
have no war until no one needs to be a
fighter firefight or whatever that will
not change because that's how men
evolved to be and women of all to be
different you talk about risk-taking et
cetera we've had evolutionary
psychologists on the show talk about
where that comes from you know the the
risk taking risk aversion differences
between men and women it's evolution
right and this is why it's so important
to take it and around as you say because
you can't just focus on one thing and go
well men are more likely to die at work
yes it's true it is true and we don't
feel less sorry for men as we do for
women but there's advantages to being a
man there are disadvantages to be
there's advantages to being a woman that
disadvantages to being a woman and what
we have to do I think is a society's get
rid of discrimination but remember that
we're not the same yeah and one of the
great things about women is women are
different to men so I reckon if you had
more women in banking for example in
2006-7 a with really powerful voices I
don't know if we would have had a
financial crash in quite the same way
because it would have been the super
hyper risk hungry people making those
decisions if you had some women who are
more risk averse with a strong voice in
that boardroom you may not have had the
same problems yeah which is why I really
think it's important that we do have
people of both sexes represented but
that has to come through as you say
through opportunity equality of
opportunity not by forcing people into
those positions yeah that sound like a
party political born was the women's
equality yeah it is an important point
to make and that leads me very nicely on
just you believe in quotas no surprise
they're not believing craters at all I
don't think any self-respecting minority
box tick wants to feel like they're
there because they're a box tick and I
think some people will tell themselves
that this is required in order to and
correct an imbalance but I think it does
nobody any favors it might correct that
imbalance in this short term I think
there's nobody any favors in the medium
to long terms and no not not fun I mean
there's a counter argument to that where
there is unconscious bias in that you're
not aware that you have a bias but you
know you only hire people that you know
local sound like you or have the same
background as you and so everybody at
the BBC comes from the same College at
Oxford or Cambridge or whatever else do
you believe that it doesn't sort of
counterbalance that and force people to
look outside the box as it were well
yeah I mean this that this this concept
that one conscious bias is now accepted
yeah and yet I understand it has been
entirely debunked scientifically there's
nobody could nobody wants to report that
I've read articles that have actually
done the research and say it's been
debunked how however I do believe
there's a little bit of people like me
hiring that goes on but I don't believe
that that is around identity boxes I
believe it's around upbringing values
you know social behaviors you know if
they went to schools you know that you
know you've automatically got that point
of reference with that individual and
you might not have some of the same
people you know London is a small place
in many respects so I do think it
happens a bit although you know I have
read that unconscious biases is
massively overstated and I I want to
give people the benefit the doubt that
there is more meritocracy and judgement
employed in those things but it's the
lack of diversity on ideology people
type and background and and viewpoints
socio-economic diversity that I think is
the biggest risk and the diversity I
think we should be focusing on other
place to the visible diversity boxes
it's it should be much more about
getting more psychological diversity
that that's where because at the moment
the out their identity box sorry I've
got off from one now the identity box
ticking only serves to help the people
you know of color all the women I've
gone through the same universities that
you know have had the fortunate you know
well supported upbringing with you know
parents that believed in them and you
know and and I've heard the argument
that well that's where you start and
then you create the role models to bring
more people through the system but at
the moment I see I see the recipients of
a lot of the diversity industry are
those people that they're that we're
doing pretty well already as a result of
you know how fortunate they were with in
education or with attitudes you know
some people are just born more
intelligent born you know more driven
and so how do we get access to those
types of people so you know the people
who grow it or grow up who want to
achieve but don't always come from the
most affluent backgrounds don't always
have the wealth of opportunity because I
one thing that really angers me is a
whole internship culture that I see
happening now and that it didn't happen
when I graduated University but after
2008 I think it gave companies a little
bit of carte blanche to stop going I'll
come and work for free and then we'll
see if you get a job or not okay I think
from what I've seen and I'm not an
expert at this and you've just asked
possibly the biggest societal challenge
question of all how do you bridge
socio-economic background I don't have
you know better melting pot of people
from all these different backgrounds I
do know that there's the tide has turned
on that free internship thing ya know
serious business offers a free
internship anymore because they have
recognized that that is not the way it's
not fair and it only rewards those that
can afford to do it as opposed to those
that can't and you know and I'm very
encouraged by you know the people I know
within the business community that
absolutely accept that and go out of
their way
to engage with schemes that are about
access for those that don't fortunate
enough to have lots of parents you know
within the school community that can
offer those those free work experiences
are some brilliant initiatives whether
it's their founders for school and
issues or the work finder Apple access
aspiration I think it's called that are
deliberately around creating networks of
mentors and schemes and opportunities
for those that don't have them within
their existing community and school
networks I'm a big big big fan of those
and do you think we should obligate
companies to I mean maybe look at if you
know if you making a certain amount of
money in profit that you should be maybe
obligated or you know to bring people in
from different socioeconomic backgrounds
or do you think it should be more
free-market
I D I'm on free market on most issues in
life but I don't see the harm in telling
strongly saying you need to get involved
in your communities in better ways but
doesn't have to be companies coming into
business we can become the company's
going into schools yeah and that's the
big way that I'm witnessing and I'm a
big part of now actually on the Advisory
Board of this fantastic initiative
called standards for schools which is
now too narrowly defines not just
founders it's all businesspeople now
going in and it can be the 21 year old
graduate you know scheme guy or it can
be a 60 year old CEO then goes in
because everybody's got some mentoring
that they can offer to those further
down the ladder to them and whether we
need to mandate it I'd say probably not
but I think if you're a responsible
business and you do it it makes you more
appealing to people that don't want to
apply to you you know it's actually self
it's of promotional in some ways to do
more of this it's getting your brand
into these schools for the talent to be
aware of as they as they get there they
graduate
[Music]
this is a question that I've always
wanted to ask because I'm a former
teacher you're someone who works in
business you're a leader what do you
think about this generation of young
people because it seems to me that a lot
of people in the media say oh you know
these at the education system it doesn't
produce you know good work because you
know the next generation they're all for
their dreadful where do you stand on
this new generation do you think they're
ready for work when they come out or do
you think which generation are talking
about away Millennials have obviously
already in the workplace are we talking
about Generation Y Jane and I I'm an
optimist I think there's there's there's
going to be so much talent coming
through I but my biggest concerns and
the another debate that I've tapped into
after I started going down the rabbit
hole of feminism was and also now as a
parent is is how we're bringing up
children and my concern and obviously
I'm very tuned in or say to the citizens
no Flake culture conversation and this
culture of safety ISM that is in
universities now so the generation at
university now is the one that was kind
of brought up with smart devices and
social media and below and I've really
started going into depth now on what's
happening to teenagers how our devices
and social media and screen time
affecting their upbringing and you know
their their sense of self and I feel
sorry for them in many ways you know I
think they think that this is the most
fun in stories technology is concerned
ever but it's also created this culture
of sort of always on mental health
anxiety desire for dopamine and you know
the kids now kind of have to have a
personal brand from the age of sort of
11 12 13 and there's this constant focus
on self and that that really worries me
and I I think what we're doing and
there's some fantastic research done by
a woman called Jean Twenge in the States
which I stumbled across through a
fantastic book which was a bit a big
influence on me
Jonathan hates and Greg lukianov and
coddling of the American mind and that
talks about how a 15 an 18 year old
today is now more like a 15 year old 10
years ago because they've been kept so
safe in and not allowed to go out not
allowed to have Saturday jobs in a not
allowed to walk to school before the age
of sort of 1213 there's this sort of
terror that there's so many evils in the
world now that we really want to protect
our children and we're no longer
preparing our children for the road but
the road for the child and that this
this coddling has dramatically impacted
how resilient children are and made the
nervous of bogeymen around every every
corner and and really had a big impact
on the maturity levels when they reach
university which is why a lot of them
want protecting from bad words nasty
conversations ideas that they don't want
to confront by the time they get there
and I think I was a very very real
phenomenon some people say it's
overstated but I think it is a real
phenomena and I think that technology
has been a big factor in that although I
also think it's down to parenting styles
and you know the the things within the
educational system that you know one has
to win anymore we were going to be you
know bullets has got to take part as
teams and you know where there's there's
so much going on around how we're
bringing up children and educating
children and I think when he's thrown
this massive missile of a 24-7 weapon of
a smartphone for teenage girls to exact
passive aggression on each other in the
middle of the night by leaving them out
of photographs or groups you know we've
is if there's a very very toxic
massively rapidly changing environment
that kids are being brought up in there
and how much responsibility do you think
the tech companies have to these types
of users because there's a huge debate
going on now does Facebook have
responsibilities instead well Facebook
on Instagram do Instagram have
responsibility is it the parents
responsibility
I do think big tech has responsive
this is my industry and you know I've
tuned into all these debates about what
they could and should be doing the first
thing I'd say is I think some of these
are inadvertent byproducts and a lot of
people will say that they're mirrors on
behaviors so just made more accessible
for the behaviors that teenagers engage
in anyway and I think you know they have
to look at how they moderate content
what they allow in the behaviors but the
fundamental problem with all of big tech
is our business models and particularly
social media business models which are
determined and reliant on dopamine
dopamine eyeballs and time spent online
so ultimately the longer you're online
and it's dopamine that feels the amount
of time you spend online the more money
they make now that is a problem and I
don't see how they can correct that
overnight and because you know that we
need to him to get offline it's been
scientifically proven that mental health
and online poor mental health and online
time is directly correlated more time
offline you know a better mental health
and I think you know there's social
media neuroses the neuroses it's caused
by social media is a massive problem so
I think tech is the problem I think
parents need to watch this I think it's
caught them unawares it needs a lot of
it's been happening in the bedrooms and
you know we're all playing catch-up on
how quickly these behavioral trends have
happened but they also think tech is the
solution so there's my entrepreneurial
optimism for you and I I think that
different business models different
communications around what's happening
and I also think that there's a new
narrative and appreciation of the
dangers of tech that's only just
starting now to get serious the last two
years we've had this sort of whimsical
oh god I'm addicted to my phone isn't it
awful asleep with it by my bed and you
know there's too much time and then
looking at screen time reports I'm
thinking god what else could I have done
with that four and a half hours today
that is like just me
probably more for us but the tide has
moved from that sort of whimsical sort
of incredulity about our tech news
to actually now thinking I resent this
there's something really not quite right
about this the fact that I cut you know
people aren't looking at each other on
the street the fact that you know we're
constantly being distracted while so in
the middle of something and we're happy
to be distracted about it the fact that
you can walk around the Louvre and 80%
of people have got their back to the art
taking selfies of the art and not
looking at it there's something
profoundly depressing that I think
people are now realizing about the
negative byproducts of these sorts of
behaviors and I think that that this
will result in a lot changing and I
believe consumers vote with their
eyeballs in amorites we really invite a
lot of parents onto Facebook and have
left them there you know that these will
it will change the behaviors and
platforms will come will go as quickly
as they've as they've come and I believe
that new tech will come up like my
business which which empowers altruism
which empowers knowledge and passion
sharing and inspiration in order to
drive people offline so that's that's my
business basically I'm trying to take
that Instagram stories format and
repurpose it into people creating
content isn't about them in their face
and whether they're looking gorgeous
today
but it's about what they love what
they're good at what they've learnt to
do and empowering other people to do it
in less than one minute so they can get
offline and actually do it and putting
that in an open web bank of that can be
searched it can be found almost like
Wikipedia and can be built upon by other
people who've got other ideas and things
that they've learnt it's it's a really
powerful thing that you were doing
because I got a comment but there was a
piece of research done that actually you
feel best about yourself not when you
achieve something but actually when you
help another person absolutely the
dopamine hits is much more profound than
a yes
you know if somebody actually says to
you wow you know I love that that that
cake bit that you taught me about it's
not a great example but you know ok que
cambian credit
but say it they learn he had to fix
something or learning how to do
something offline or a new yoga pose or
an hour crafting you know and they say
oh I did that and then I changed the
color scheme and I added this to it and
look what I built and if somebody sends
you that image or the video what they've
created off the back of something that
you taught them how to do he's just
gonna have this sense of all the you
know that that child got that toy that
their parent made for them or they had
that party they had that really fun game
because I told them what that game was
and they found it out because of me so
I'd love I don't know how naive it is
the thing that we're gonna shift the
tide immediately because that people
somebody likes me somebody loves me
dopamine hit is the most powerful
motivator on earth you know everybody
it's got status in it it's got
validation it's got friendship it's you
know that and that's what all those
business models are powering yeah and I
believe we compared it in a way that
delivers something that that is more
fulfilling in the long term and and tech
my business is is trying to work out how
we get those those hooks firing less
fortunate than you always very important
that's why I like
[Music]
obviously someone's very optimistic and
just to take two we've got about 10-15
minutes left to take us back to the
whole conversation about men women all
of that how do we move to a more
constructive way of talking about these
things because you know we had that
horrible shooting in New Zealand
recently it will be a couple of weeks by
a time though this episode goes out
probably and you have the leader of the
women's equality party in this country
can remember her name coming out and
saying this was all this this is just
toxic masculinity that's the cause of
this stuff and it seems like we're using
everything now to make these very narrow
political points about men and women and
all this stuff so how do we how do we
move forward positively from here I have
I am there's a very good TED talk that I
did where I talk about my positive the
positive solutions as I see it and I
think we we need to broaden the context
of the whole discussion and that's I
guess another one my biggest concerns
and there's the undermining of
confidence and women and the victimhood
mentality but there's also the fact that
we're seemingly not allowed to have so
many of these discussions and we need to
stop shutting people down for broadening
them or or asking things in different
direction to allow men to be in a debate
more not just on one side they're
allowed in the debate as long as they're
singing from this song sheet that you
know all men bad or women good and
that's just so binary and it's it's
unfair and it's not accurate and there's
nothing positive about that narrative
and that's that's what concerns me you
know we shouldn't be teaching girls
about powerful girls should be teaching
boys about powerful girls you know and
and powerful people generally and and
appreciating that you know we're all
individuals
first and foremost and beautiful crazy
you know different unusual indistinct in
our own rights and I guess that's what I
want to see because what's happening is
it takes Oaks
away from areas where I believe
prejudice and discrimination does still
exist you know whether that
socioeconomic or whether if you if you
just want to keep it on feminism you
know everything that's happening with
women and her jobs in the Middle East
you know that's real desperate feminism
in action there isn't being supportive
and has got nothing to do with you know
they're auditioning and offices yeah
yeah oh man spreading and mansplaining
and you know there's so much oxygen
being lost on the little things when
there's so many big issues to come up
with and I think having a more healthy
and open debate around it one that isn't
gender pay gap equals discrimination but
actually oh interestingly gender pay gap
also can reflect choice and positive
decisions that women make to reclaim
more balance in their lives and you know
we won't go off on that I know you've
done quite a bit on gender pay gap
previously well you you're a good
example of that you talk about yourself
having three children or four years and
how that changed your attitude to to
your working mode and everything else
right so tell us more about that well I
would like to see more women like me
publicly saying that because the number
of people that have come up to me after
I've put myself on the line a little bit
about this and said oh thank you
you know I I totally agree with you you
know I've chosen to spend time you know
these years at home you know I've chosen
to I don't want to make partner anymore
why would I want to do that it's a
masochistic unpleasant life of long
hours no balanced politics and stress in
life is too short and you know I this is
what I choose and the gender pay gap
between me and my husband and our 90
percent 100 percent and and men of
course often say thank you for saying
this because I'm not allowed to and I
won't you'll add to you've got a wife
you love dearly you've got daughters
that you care about you know you're not
you do not not have a vested interest in
in this debate but that won't save you
now that's the thing is like buzz
Francis and iPod and they're like I
talked to my wife about this and she's
she's probably more against this stuff
than I am in some ways she's probably
less understanding of all this victim
have danaiah because I'm like well did
but this happens but this happens and
she has a very similar idea to she's
like what you just you know of course
there's discrimination but you power
through it or you deal with it and she
can say that but if a man was to say
that and and we know this for example in
comedy with Francis and I were talking
just before you got here you know it's
perfectly normal now to go into a comedy
club and see a woman talking about how
men are trash on stage that's comedy now
I know you know and you just kind of go
well of course you know not all men are
perfect and there are problems with
masculinity but that level of vitriol
that you have now is it's gone to a
level which I find very difficult to
understand that people sit there and
kind of take it you know what I mean
yeah and what what what concerns me the
most is the lack of kindness in the tone
of the debate you know there's a there's
a huge amount of anger thrown around and
sort of nasty hiss taking and shutting
down and that to me doesn't further any
debate or discussion and it means there
isn't room for all these different
voices and if people are scared to raise
their head on something as fundamental
as you know whether they have the right
to feel you know optimistic about their
opportunities in life or not then
there's something seriously wrong there
and I don't and I have a perfectly nice
I have found it actually really hard I
tried to do a micro version on my TED
talk at a media advertising conference a
few months back and I chose perhaps
unwisely to then open that up to a
workshop afterwards done it
as a as a TEDTalk and not as as a debate
I'm actually not that strong a debater I
kind of can get a bit flustered and kind
of forget the angle so you know I hate
something like news night or anyone of
those sorts of shows and but I chose to
open it up and people were so nasty and
they made it very very ad hominem about
me and you know as well you're all right
you haven't experienced this you haven't
experienced that and and I took it all
and I ended up totally on the back post
and said oh well you know it may be
maybe you're right and then I went away
and thought about I said no I'm I I'd
never know if I spoken to enough people
I've lived in this world and I'm even if
I'm only allowed if you only allow me to
talk about the fields that I know
there's something very wrong with in
those fields or within some of the
narrative around it I just don't
understand why I have to why it has to
be so unpleasantly and shut down let's
have a conversation habitual is
incredible and it happens particularly
when people from supposedly oppressed
groups speak out that's when it seems to
be extra vicious doesn't it like we've
had people on the show from people who
are black or female or whatever talking
about you know there isn't that much
racism or isn't this particular problem
and those people get some of the most
vicious abuse from their from with the
people who think they're on their side
you know but that just means we're never
gonna have any introverts go into public
life yeah in any way and introverts are
often the most thoughtful people on this
earth you know there's a reason why
they've weighed these things that
they've thought about it I mean James
d'amour sorry oh yeah that's the one I
can literally Vice Adm I can literally
throw a bomb into a roomful of tech
women and I you know I I thought that
whole debate wasn't debate that needed
to be had no matter where you fell on
inside of what he was saying this is a
nerdy introverted guy who actually got
away and done a lot of research er
distilled it and was asking some
interesting questions now you can
disagree with the conclusions he came to
but you shouldn't I personally don't
know
and that you you shouldn't disagree with
his ability to be able to have that
conversation and that to me was
symptomatic of so much of the level of
debate that when why are we not allowed
to have that conversation you're not
feeding one for the other it's this
whole some disinfectant of sunlight on
an issue and obviously back to big tech
again there's this huge debate around
how you know the sort of political sort
of social ideologies of these these tech
companies are now arbitrating in a way
that is fundamentally affecting that
debate as well you know with with
certain viewpoints totally you know and
shut down and Bandhan and sure you know
more about that than I do but it's
happening on an everyday level in
everyday conversations and that's what
concerns me that is not a popular view
you know the the 14.5 thousand retweets
at this poor tech bug demonstrate that
there's a right on way of being able to
talk about these issues and what amuses
me if they all think that they're like
some great activists around these issues
I'm like this is an activism this is the
line this is the line that is acceptable
my lines not acceptable on some of these
issues and I can get crucified for and
have done very very personally so I
don't tend to do this in open forums
anymore well this is only going on the
internet but there is there is a
giveaway in that attitude of having to
share people down which is your by
shutting someone down instead of
engaging with their argument and
defeating their argument what you're
really saying is I know that right you
that's what you're really saying because
if you if they were wrong you would just
prove them wrong well if you have to
shut someone down that means their
arguments actually are accurate because
otherwise why would you have to shut
them down well I think I'm not sure I
agree with that I do but the point is
you're not why would you not want to
disprove that argument but that's my
point
wrong well it's because you're scared of
it in some way why
No right I just don't know I just think
always more polite interesting
intellectual non personal way of
discussing these issues is the way to go
and I'm not quite sure how we kind of
reverse a lot of these tone of the
debate and you know the because it's
exacerbated so much by their social
media tools and the way in which
mainstream media has had to it's got to
go to their clickbait extreme of any
argument and it means that there's
nothing is allowed to be gray anymore
and that's that's a real worry because
everything's great everything nothing is
black and white such a British point of
view everything it's because you hear
you know and you see these titles you
know smashes so and so you know you know
crushes whatever and you think well all
they're really talking about his ideas
isn't discussion at its best when you
say something to me and I got wide shot
there before bang on that you know maybe
she's got a point
I'm gonna go away and whatever think I'm
gonna change what I think yeah and I'm
going to evolve as a person a human
being but we don't do that anymore but
it's about ego now it's I have to beat
you
yeah and ultimately nobody really learns
anything and it's also everything is a
soundbite yeah I probably said for
example three or four things within this
chat that might not have been that well
considered and that I'll go and I'll
watch it again and I think those will be
the clips we use that will get right at
me you know the next time I you know
somebody somebody would have done their
research and when I'm fabulously Mark
Zuckerberg esque with my new platform
tick check it out it's free outdoor you
know that they'll find something you
know they're ill-advised
but I will have said today in some
context and all of this sort of lots of
controversy and you can hear it in the
way I talk I'm working all this stuff
out for myself and I think this is such
a cathartic way for us to learn from
each other and throw these ideas around
and yet there are so few forums like
this and the one that you've put
together with trigonometry that really
enable us to do that and that
that's it this is a shame well that is
what we're trying to do you know the
final thing either the cause of the
alright yeah apparently that's someone's
gonna take that literally I know it
sounds better in my voice as well as
sounds more authentic doesn't it
you don't sound I always think all right
as Americans though you don't sound all
right you just sound racist yeah the
final thing I always feel like it's
important when we talk about this men
and women stuff that we also address the
fact that there are some men who've gone
off the deep end as well as you say as a
result of this toxicity on both sides so
you have all these in cells and these
people running around going well women
are always complaining all this stuff
and it's like no that doesn't help
either you know men and women need to
come together the two groups of people
historically that have always needed to
cooperate more than any other groups is
men and women mm-hm and it you know you
look at any successful person they
probably have a very healthy
relationships with people of the other
sex because that's how you live life by
dealing with other people you know and
if you if you have those unhealthy
attitudes you're gonna struggle whatever
it is you're doing you know and that
worries me as well I think that it's
it's great that you hear a lot of people
you know people like we talked about Joe
Rogan and people like others and I was
trying to remind men as well that don't
be a dick that's also part of part of
the cut that also has to be part of the
conversation because a lot of men are
resentful now they are resentful is what
they see is a kind of war on men yeah
and you know some of there is a
legitimate argument to be made that we
live in a society where men are kind of
stigmatized for being men but the answer
to that isn't to become a dick the
answer to that is to try and have more
conversations to try and learn about
stuff to try and bring the conversation
back to the middle and that's why we
were always very grateful to have guests
like you to come on and talk to us about
that so let's have a final question
right okay can I just say that you said
men and women come together and I didn't
make a joke about it and I'm so proud of
myself I'm evolving as a human being
which is the exact same thing that every
woman in my life does but just just to
finish up we always end on this question
what is the one thing that we're taught
where that we should be talking about a
society that we're not really
yeah you've given me an hour where
you've made me talk throughout the whole
hour to think about my answers to this
question and so it's a sort of summary
in some way of a lot the stuff we've
been talking about it's this obsession
on self selfie me my identity there's
something that I don't think is being
discussed enough is this sort of the
very narcissistic unpleasant nature of
you me me sorry yeah it worries me that
we are that nobody is actually saying
well actually you know all this time in
our own heads thinking about ourselves
and our mindfulness and our mental
health and our gender and our identity
and what we want and what we can
contribute to the world and our values
and our what's the the trendy thing at
the moment is what's your purpose what's
your purpose in life and I kind of think
well that's not a healthy that's a
healthy culture if we're all obsessing
about us and what we want what we're
doing and and you know the onus is being
lost and I think the selfie itself is
the most symptomatic visual
representation of a culture that is
dangerously obsessed with self so yeah
big big are we talking about that enough
I think we are and in lots of sort of
different issues but that to me kind of
encapsulates it and we kind of want to
say really stop looking at yourself and
then together eventually talks about
Willys right okay so and on that note
yeah great note so I'm sorry about him
about me just thank you so much for
coming on the show your Twitter is act
Jeff butcher had just my business hey I
was about to blow I think yeah I was
about to plug it it stick and it's
available on the App Store yes so it's
for tech done on the Apple Store Android
coming racing fantastic as always follow
us at trigger pod on Twitter Instagram
Facebook click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified of
when the video comes out subscribe to
the YouTube channel if you haven't
already for more great videos give us an
iTunes review blah blah blah we'll see
you in a week from now absolutely also
as well just check to see if you haven't
been up son subscribed it always happens
please check out and thanks and also
just kind of friend about us spread the
word spread the hate speak soon bye bye
[Music]